[Music]
so the one thing we know for sure about
kamala harris is we should all be very
very grateful to have her because she's
historic for reasons that no one ever
explains but there's a lot we don't know
about kamala harris most people probably
don't know she really grew up in canada
that's where she went to high school
she's not
from this country in that sense or she's
certainly also from canada okay didn't
know that doesn't mean she's not going
to be a good vice president but why
haven't we heard that by the way how did
someone who clearly
is not liked by the people around her
and clearly isn't very good at her job
get
so high up well we know her first
meaningful job in politics was given to
her by her boyfriend at the time who's
married willie brown
most powerful democrat in california but
we know that willie brown is not the
only powerful person she dated and this
is pretty interesting we're not exactly
sure what to make of it but it turns out
that kamala harris also dated the
tabloid tv show host montel williams was
always doing shows about people's weird
sex lives we know that because of this
video watch
long before she met doug emhoff she
dated some prominent men including in
2001 former talk show host montel
williams back then he was the famous one
and had to introduce her to the
paparazzi
[Applause]
so we know that monte williams called
her kamala we also she calls herself
kamala sometimes but that's kind of all
we know so what was that relationship
like what did montel williams think of
it so we would love to talk to montel
williams about his torrid relationship
with kamilar kamala
because that
might be one of those blanks we'd like
to fill in anyway he is always welcome
on this show meantime we know that
kamala harris
having some problems as vice president
cnn has just published this report and
by the way they spent a long time
telling us how great she is and how
thrilled we should be to have her but
now they're telling us this is the name
of the piece exasperation and
dysfunction inside kamala harris's
frustrating start as vice president
in other words it's kind of a disaster
which they told us about earlier
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else